From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass.
这里是芝加哥 WBEZ 电台的《美国生活》，我是艾拉·格拉斯。
My profession that I was in as a conservation officer, state and federal, was not a job. It was a vision quest.
我之前从事的州和联邦资源保护官员的职业，那不仅仅是一份工作，更是一场追寻理想的旅程。
Ladies and gentlemen, meet Terry Grosz, retired California state fish and game warden; retired special agent, from 1981 to 1998, with the US Fish and Wildlife Service.
女士们先生们，这位是特里·格罗兹，退休的加州鱼类及野生动物保护官；1981 年至 1998 年任职于美国鱼类及野生动物管理局的退休特别探员。
I was in charge of North and South Dakota, Nebraska, Kansas, Montana, Wyoming, Colorado, and Utah.
我负责北达科他州、南达科他州、内布拉斯加州、堪萨斯州、蒙大拿州、怀俄明州、科罗拉多州和犹他州。
Author of a dozen books, he has heard of the Terry Gross on Public Radio, but does not listen to her. Not his thing. He has personally nabbed thousands of people who were killing birds and fish and game illegally, taking wildlife illegally, smuggling wildlife illegally, selling wildlife parts and products, and committing other violations. He takes it to heart that whole populations of animals can get killed off. His philosophy--
作为十几本书的作者，他听说过公共广播电台的那位特里·格罗斯，但从不听她的节目。那不是他的菜。他亲手抓获过数千名非法捕杀鸟类、鱼类和猎物，非法获取、走私野生动物，销售野生动物制品并犯有其他违规行为的人。动物种群可能被赶尽杀绝，这件事让他深感痛心。他的哲学是——
Wildlife dies without making a sound. So the only voice it's got is yours. And as a law enforcement officer, if you're not squalling like a smashed cat-- and my pardon to the cat lovers out there-- then you're not doing your job.
野生动物在死亡时发不出任何声音，所以它们唯一的代言人就是你。作为执法人员，如果你不发出像被碾压的猫那样的尖叫——请原谅那些猫咪爱好者——那你就是在失职。
In fact, as he says, what this mean to him was total dedication. Do whatever had to be done. One time he laid in the marsh for 58 hours to catch one particularly egregious duck hunter. Another time he got a tip that a poacher was after this one herd of elk. He slept with the elk to protect them, night after night.
事实上，正如他所说，对他而言这意味着全然的奉献。必须做什么就去做。有一次，为了抓捕一个特别恶劣的猎鸭者，他在沼泽地里趴了 58 个小时。还有一次，他得到线报说有偷猎者盯上了一群麋鹿。他便每晚与麋鹿睡在一起保护它们。
But my favorite story of his involves deceit and ingenuity. It was when Terry was still in his 20s, a fish and game warden in Eureka, California. He was what they called the floating game warden, which meant that he would cover for three other officers when they were sick or on leave.
但我最喜欢他讲的故事是关于欺骗与智慧的。那时特里才 20 多岁，是加州尤里卡的鱼类及野生动物保护官。他被称为“流动保护官”，这意味着当其他三名官员生病或休假时，他负责顶替他们的工作。
And in those days, we had salmon like you couldn't believe in Northern California. They don't so much anymore. An awful lot of the species have dwindled away due to a lot of environmental problems and illegal take. But, gosh, we had salmon everywhere. If you weren't careful, when you drank a glass of water, you'd find a salmon in it. I mean they were really plentiful.
在那个年代，北加州的鲑鱼数量多得让你难以置信。现在已经没那么多了。由于许多环境问题和非法捕捞，很多物种已经减少。但是，天哪，到处都是鲑鱼。如果不小心的话，你喝杯水都能在里面发现一条鲑鱼。我是说，它们真的非常多。
And it was part of my job to check the salmon fishermen because we had an awful lot of outlaws that would snag them, dynamite them, gillnet them, just people shooting them in the shallows when they were going up through the riffles. I mean it was just unbelievable.
检查鲑鱼渔民是我工作的一部分，因为有太多的不法之徒会用钩子钩它们、用炸药炸它们、用流刺网捕它们，甚至在它们穿过浅滩时直接射杀。我是说，简直令人难以置信。
He says it was especially a problem on the Eel River, near Fortuna, California, where men were illegally fishing in the middle of the night. The law said they had to stop a half hour after sunset. But they would be there at 2:00 or 3:00 in the morning. And they were able to haul in usually huge catches because the fish there were resting in pools in the river like-- OK, like sitting ducks, if I could just mix animal metaphors for a second.
他说在加州福图纳附近的鳗鱼河，这尤其是一个问题，那里的人在半夜非法捕鱼。法律规定他们必须在日落半小时后停止捕鱼。但他们会在凌晨 2 点或 3 点出现在那里。他们通常能捕获大量的鱼，因为鱼群在河里的深潭中休息，就像——好吧，如果允许我稍微混用一下动物比喻的话——就像瓮中之鳖。
And these fishermen used this special glow-in-dark lure that was just unstoppable. They would shine a flashlight on this lure. And it would glow, called a Glo Pup. In the middle of the night--
这些渔民使用一种特别的夜光诱饵，简直势不可挡。他们用手电筒照这种诱饵，它就会发光，叫“Glo Pup”。在深夜里——
That bright lure would be going through a dark pool. These King salmon would just instinctively strike at it. And these guys were catching fish like crazy. And these were 35, up to 60, pound King salmon, that were heading upstream to spawn. And it was a terrible bit of destruction on the fish population.
那个明亮的诱饵在黑暗的深潭中穿梭。这些王鲑会本能地发起攻击。这些人捕鱼捕得疯狂。这些都是重达 35 到 60 磅的王鲑，正逆流而上去产卵。这对鱼群来说是一场可怕的毁灭。
Because they wouldn't get a chance to spawn?
因为它们没有机会产卵了吗？
Yeah. They wouldn't. I mean they just flat didn't get out of that pool.
是的。它们没有。我是说，它们根本没能逃出那个深潭。
But these illegal fishermen were hard to catch because they set up lookouts on the road, they would see Terry and the other wardens coming. Then, one day, Terry got an idea. It came to him when his dog brought him an old leather welder's glove that it had found. And then he borrowed a wetsuit from his buddy, who was--
但这些非法渔民很难抓，因为他们会在路上设置岗哨，看到特里和其他保护官来就会逃跑。有一天，特里想到了一个主意。这主意是在他的狗叼给他一只捡到的旧皮质焊接手套时想到的。然后他从朋友那里借了一件潜水服，那朋友——
Pretty much my size. I was 6' 4", 300 in those days.
跟我身材差不多。我那时候身高 6 英尺 4 英寸，体重 300 磅。
IRA GLASS: And that night, around 9:00 o'clock Terry says, he went to the Eel River, about a mile downstream from this pool that he knew the guys would be illegally fishing. It's called Singley Pool.
艾拉·格拉斯：特里说，那天晚上 9 点左右，他去了鳗鱼河，距离他知道这些人非法捕鱼的那个深潭下游约一英里的地方。那地方叫辛格利深潭。
And I'm dressed and got into the wetsuit. And then inside the wetsuit, I had a citation book in a plastic bag and a three-cell flashlight, zipped it up. And I walked into the river. And like a damn dummy, there all by myself, 30 foot of water, colder than the dickens.
我穿上潜水服。潜水服里面有一个塑料袋装的传票簿和一个三节电池的手电筒，我把它拉上拉链。然后我走进河里。像个大傻瓜一样，独自一人在 30 英尺深的水里，冷得要命。
IRA GLASS: Oh, so now you really were the floating game warden.
艾拉·格拉斯：哦，所以现在你真的是“流动保护官”了。
Well, I don't if I was floating. I was doing as sinking as I was doing floating because I was trying to be quiet.
好吧，我不知道我是不是在浮动。我当时是在下沉，因为我试图保持安静。
IRA GLASS: And could you see much?
艾拉·格拉斯：你能看清东西吗？
Well, no. But I knew which way the river was flowing. And I knew when my feet touched, I'd be in shallow water. So I was swimming against the current. And I knew in my mind what Singley Pool looked like. At the headwaters of Singley Pool, I could see Glo Pups flying through the air.
唔，看不清。但我知道河流的流向。我知道当我的脚触到底部时，我就在浅水区了。所以我逆流而行。我在脑海里知道辛格利深潭的样子。在辛格利深潭的上游，我能看到“Glo Pups”在空中飞来飞去。
IRA GLASS: He's maybe 30 yards offshore, he says. He can see four people, backlit. There's a little light coming from a ranch house that's there. And he can the glow of their cigarettes. But it's really dark.
艾拉·格拉斯：他说他离岸边大概 30 码。他能看到四个人，背着光。那儿有个牧场屋透出一点点光。他还能看到他们抽烟的火星。但天色真的很暗。
Three of them were fishing. One guy was just standing there. So I just kept swimming towards them and trying to get to their lures. And I'd move my hand back out of the leather glove to where just my fingers are inside the palm part of the glove. And the leather glove fingers are just kind of dangling out there with no fingers in them.
其中三个人在钓鱼。一个人就站在那儿。所以我只是继续游向他们，试图接近他们的诱饵。我把手从皮手套里缩回来，只让手指留在手套的掌心部分。皮手套的手指就在外面晃荡，里面没有手指。
This is the idea that he got when the dog brought him this glove.
这就是当狗把手套带给他时，他想到的主意。
And when finally a lure came by kind of close, I slapped at it. And I missed the first one. And I heard one of the guys say, "god, did you hear that salmon roll out there?" Of course, you can't see anything. And I'm out there in the river in a dark wetsuit, with no light on.
当终于有一个诱饵靠近时，我拍了一下。第一次没拍中。我听到其中一个人说：“天哪，你听到鲑鱼在外面翻腾的声音了吗？”当然，你什么也看不见。我正穿着深色潜水服，没开灯地在河里。
And the next one came by and it was close enough. And I grabbed it. And it hooked onto the glove, the finger part of the glove. And I gave a big jerk. And I heard, zhrrz. And he said, "fish on. Fish on."
下一个诱饵过来了，距离刚好。我一把抓住。它钩在了手套的手指部位。我用力一拽。我听到了“滋”的一声。他说：“上钩了，上钩了。”
I'm flopping and splashing, hanging onto this guy's lure as he's pulling. And I'm slapping my left hand in the water, like the fish is fighting. And he kept saying, "gosh, it's a big one. It's huge." I kept pulling and tugging.
我一边挣扎一边拍打，抓着这家伙的诱饵，他正在拉扯。我用左手拍打水面，就像鱼在挣扎一样。他不停地说：“天哪，这是一条大鱼，太大了。”我继续拉扯和拽动。
And you're floating too.
你也在浮着。
Oh, yeah.
哦，是的。
So he's getting the feeling of like this is what it's like to reel in--
所以他感觉就像是在收线钓到了一——
Yep.
没错。
--a fish.
——条鱼。
Yep. I'm pulling against his line. And I'm jerking it. And then I'm jerking line out. Because I know if they see me, once I get close to shore, they're going to run. So I got to keep them kind of close at hand.
没错。我用力对抗他的鱼线。我在拽它，然后我往外拽线。因为我知道如果他们看到我，一旦我靠近岸边，他们就会跑。所以我得让他们尽量保持在手边。
So the guy that's got me is getting really excited. And finally he said, "god, this the biggest salmon I ever got. I bet it weighs a hundred pounds." Well, he was 200 pounds off.
抓着我的那个人变得非常兴奋。最后他说：“天哪，这是我钓过最大的鲑鱼。我打赌它得有一百磅重。”好吧，他猜轻了 200 磅。
And finally I heard somebody say, "get the net. Get the net." And another voice said, "get the net, heck-- get a gun."
最后我听到有人说：“拿网来，拿网来。”另一个声音说：“拿网？去你的——拿把枪来。”
Terry says he was too young and dumb to get scared about that. And they didn't get a gun.
特里说他当时太年轻太愚蠢，没感到害怕。而且他们也没拿枪。
Anyway, finally I felt my feet hit the bottom, where I could walk. So I kept tugging and pulling, and tugging and pulling. And he's groaning. And it was hard to keep from laughing because I knew this guy was going to be surprised.
总之，我终于感觉到脚触到了底，可以走路了。所以我继续拉扯和拽动。他累得呻吟。很难憋住不笑，因为我知道这家伙待会儿会很惊讶。
Anyway, I finally got right up on them. And like I said, it's dark as the dickens. And then I turned on my little three-cell flashlight. And I said, "good morning, gentleman. State fish and game warden, you're under arrest."
总之，我终于走到了他们跟前。就像我说的，天黑得像锅底。然后我打开了我的小手电筒。我说：“早上好，先生们。州鱼类及野生动物保护官，你们被逮捕了。”
The guy that had me, he's got the pole almost doubled, he's pulling so hard. And he goes, "oh, oh, oh."
那个抓着我的家伙，他的钓竿几乎弯成了两半，他拉得太用力了。他喊道：“哦，哦，哦。”
He dropped to the ground. Terry thought he gave him a heart attack. But he came to. He was fine.
他瘫倒在地上。特里以为他突发心脏病了。但他醒过来了，没事。
The guys on either side of him, two of them were attorneys. They just stood there. They didn't even move. And I think it was just out of shock. So I walked up on the bank and then I had them because I was within grabbing distance.
他身边的两个人，其中两个是律师。他们只是站在那儿，连动都没动。我想那纯粹是被吓傻了。所以我走上岸，因为我在抓捕范围内，所以我控制住了他们。
And when I got all through, I had them sign the citations. I put the cite book back in my plastic bag. Put that back inside the wetsuit. Said do you have any more questions, gentlemen? And they're still in shock.
一切结束后，我让他们签了传票。我把传票簿放回塑料袋，塞回潜水服里。问他们：“还有问题吗，先生们？”他们仍然处于震惊中。
So I gather up all their fishing rods because I seized it. It was illegal gear. And into the river I walked and quietly swam away.
于是我收缴了他们所有的钓竿，因为这是非法装备。我就这样走回河里，静静地游走了。
I should say, we checked with the public affairs officer at the Fish and Wildlife office where Terry worked. And he confirmed that, yes, this was a thing for a while back in the day, game wardens emerging out of the rivers to catch illegal fishing. Terry tells the story in his memoir, Wildlife Wars. Terry says, unconventional methods, that is just what's called for sometimes.
我应该说，我们咨询了特里工作过的鱼类及野生动物管理局的公共事务官员。他证实说，是的，这在当时确实是一种常见的做法，保护官从河里冒出来抓捕非法钓鱼者。特里在他的回忆录《野生动物战争》中讲述了这个故事。特里说，非传统的手段，有时正是工作所需的。
Later today on our radio program, That's One Way to Do It, we have two stories of people who make choices that are very different from what is expected of them, including a woman who cozied up to one of America's enemies, looking to fix a problem here at home. I'm talking about people who come to the fork in the river of salmon and they swim down the path less traveled. And that makes all the difference. Stay with us.
稍后我们的广播节目中，主题是《那是一种方法》，我们将带来两个关于人们做出与预期截然不同的选择的故事，其中包括一位接近美国敌人，寻求解决国内问题的女性。我说的就是那些来到鲑鱼河分叉口，选择走那条人迹罕至之路的人。而这带来了全部的不同。请继续收听。
Act One, Sex, Boyhood and Politics in South Carolina.
第一幕：性、男孩生活与南卡罗来纳州的政治。
So this is, of course, a perfect election year for the theme That's One Way to Do it. The That's One Way to Do It candidate, Donald Trump, is crushing his adversaries with unconventional politicking; Bernie Sanders, a very similar story.
当然，对于《那是一种方法》这个主题来说，今年绝对是完美的选举年。候选人唐纳德·特朗普正以非传统的政治手段压倒对手；伯尼·桑德斯的故事也非常相似。
One our producers, Zoe Chace, was in South Carolina this last month and was surprised by some of the voters as well, one in particular.
我们的一位制作人佐伊·蔡斯上个月在南卡罗来纳州，也对一些选民感到惊讶，其中特别是一位。
I was traveling around the state talking to groups like, Students for Trump--
我在全州旅行，与像“学生支持特朗普”这样的组织交谈——
Yeah.
没错。
--a group of high schoolers. That's how I happened to talk to Alex Chalgren. He's one of the most oddly formal 18-year-olds I've ever met.
——一个高中生组织。我就是在那时和亚历克斯·查尔格伦聊上的。他是我见过最奇特、最老成持重的 18 岁少年。
My name is Alex Chalgren. I'm the South Carolina director for Students for Trump. And I live in Columbia, South Carolina.
我叫亚历克斯·查尔格伦。我是南卡罗来纳州“学生支持特朗普”组织的负责人。我住在南卡罗来纳州的哥伦比亚市。
So put together, he made me nervous. After he told me where he was from, I asked him where he was from.
所以加在一起，他让我感到紧张。在他告诉我他来自哪里后，我问他他是从哪里来的。
We are in Columbia, South Carolina.
我们在南卡罗来纳州的哥伦比亚市。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
We're at the Blue Marlin, more specifically, sort of a seafood restaurant, local, yeah, restaurant.
我们在“蓝枪鱼”餐厅，更具体地说，这是一家海鲜餐厅，本地的餐厅。
Do you come here often?
你经常来这儿吗？
I do, with my father.
是的，和我父亲一起来。
I could tell right away that Alex is one of those kids that adults adore. He's like a little old person. I was sitting around this outside table with the high schoolers for Trump. And Alex stood out in a million ways from the group.
我立刻就能看出亚历克斯属于那种大人们会疼爱的孩子。他就像个小老头。我和这群支持特朗普的高中生坐在外面的桌子旁。亚历克斯在好几百万种方式上都与众不同。
He's the only black kid, the only one in a tie, biggest smile, loudest laugh, super friendly, and charismatic. He's just striking. So it wasn't that surprising when he mentioned offhand that he'd been chosen to ask a question at the first Republican debate.
他是唯一的黑人孩子，唯一打领带的，笑容最灿烂，笑声最大，超级友好且富有魅力。他非常引人注目。所以当他随口提到他被选中在首场共和党辩论中提问时，我并不感到惊讶。
I really want to get to a Facebook questioner. His name is Alex Chalgren. And he has the following question.
我真的很想联系一位 Facebook 的提问者。他的名字叫亚历克斯·查尔格伦。他有以下问题。
My question is, how would the candidates stop the treacherous actions of ISIS, ISIL, and it's growing influence in the US if they were to become president?
我的问题是，如果各位候选人当选总统，将如何制止伊斯兰国（ISIS、ISIL）的背叛行径及其在美国日益增长的影响力？
Oh.
哦。
And then my Instagram, my Twitter, my phone just started ringing off the hook. It's amazing. It was amazing. It was a huge-- it was a huge thing.
然后我的 Instagram、我的 Twitter、我的电话就开始响个不停。太神奇了。这太棒了。这是一个巨大的——这是一件大事。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
That really changed my life for the better.
这真的让我的生活变得更好了。
It changed his life because not long after that, a group called Students for Trump reached out to Alex on Instagram. They asked Alex if he would get involved in the Trump campaign. And that quick, Alex became an active Trump supporter. Now, Alex was already a conservative for all the reasons that Republicans like Republicans more than Democrats.
这改变了他的生活，因为在那之后不久，一个叫“学生支持特朗普”的组织在 Instagram 上联系了亚历克斯。他们问亚历克斯是否愿意参与特朗普的竞选。很快，亚历克斯就成了特朗普的积极支持者。其实，亚历克斯本来就是一个保守派，原因和共和党人比民主党人更喜欢共和党人没什么两样。
I've had to work to where I am today, education and things like that. And I was adopted. I've had work to where I am. Because I was born to a very destitute family.
我努力工作才有了今天的地位，教育以及其他方面的事情。而且我是被领养的。我必须努力才能有今天。因为我出生在一个非常贫困的家庭。
And so seeing someone like Bernie Sanders saying that he's going to redistribute the wealth and sort of give free college and free education and all that sort of humbug. Then I say to myself, he doesn't appreciate those that have nothing and have had to work so diligently to have a future. Because I plan on going to law school and all that sort good jazz.
所以看到像伯尼·桑德斯这样的人说他要重新分配财富，提供免费大学、免费教育以及所有那些乱七八糟的事情时，我就会对自己说，他不尊重那些一无所有、为了未来必须勤奋工作的人。因为我计划去读法学院，做那些好事。
And when I asked him the question I was asking everybody I was meeting down there, why Trump, Alex gave me a reason I did not expect. I was like wait, did I hear right? Your main concern is what?
当我问他那个我见到每个人都会问的问题“为什么是特朗普”时，亚历克斯给出了一个我没想到的理由。我当时想，等等，我没听错吧？你的主要关切是什么？
Yeah. Trump is fine with gay marriage, thank goodness. And he's a realist. He knows that as society moves on, we must move on. That's a part of it.
是的。特朗普对同性婚姻没意见，谢天谢地。他是个现实主义者。他知道随着社会发展，我们也必须前进。这是其中的一部分。
Gay marriage, that's not even an issue anymore, I thought. This was mid-January when I met Alex, pre-Iowa, pre-New Hampshire. It had not come up in the debates much. The candidates were not talking about it. And it's Alex's biggest issue?
同性婚姻，那甚至不再是个议题了，我想。我遇到亚历克斯时是 1 月中旬，在爱荷华州和新罕布什尔州初选之前。辩论中并没有怎么提到它。候选人们也没在谈论它。而这竟然是亚历克斯最关心的议题？
That's why I picked him really. That's why I picked him. Because my biggest concern is gay marriage and the economy. For example, if it comes down to Ted Cruz or Bernie Sanders, I might not vote or I might vote for Bernie Sanders.
所以我确实选择了他。这就是为什么我选择他。因为我最关心的是同性婚姻和经济。例如，如果最终是泰德·克鲁兹对决伯尼·桑德斯，我可能不会投票，或者我可能会投给伯尼·桑德斯。
That's how big gay marriage is to you?
同性婚姻对你来说就这么重要吗？
Yeah. Honestly. I mean I'll tell you why. I'll tell you why.
是的。老实说。我是说我会告诉你为什么。我会告诉你为什么。
I'm gay. And so it's big for me. And everyone knows I'm gay. Everyone knows I'm gay. My parents know. Everyone knows. But yeah, that's-- where are you all going?
我是同性恋。所以这对我很重要。每个人都知道我是同性恋。每个人都知道我是同性恋。我父母也知道。每个人都知道。但是，是的，那是——你们要去哪儿？
The other students for Trump kids scurry off to a corner to consult after this remark. And I find out it's because they're worried I'll lump them in with Alex and peg them as Sanders supporters over Cruz.
其他“学生支持特朗普”的孩子在听到这句话后匆匆躲到角落商量。我发现那是因为他们担心我会把他们和亚历克斯归为一类，或者认为他们是支持桑德斯而不是克鲁兹的人。
Trump's record on gay marriage at that point, scant at best. Not one of his applause lines, not getting much mention at all. I guess Alex can believe what he wants. Ted Cruz, proudly evangelical, proudly against gay marriage. So that's how Alex made his choice.
特朗普当时在同性婚姻上的记录少之又少。这根本不是他的掌声来源，一点儿也没被提到。我想亚历克斯可以相信他想相信的。泰德·克鲁兹，自豪的福音派，自豪地反对同性婚姻。所以亚历克斯就是这样做出选择的。
Then Alex tells me he's managed to alienate and confuse lots of people with his peculiar brand of politics. Trump haters turned against him on social media.
然后亚历克斯告诉我，他用他这种奇特的政治品牌成功地疏远并困惑了很多人。厌恶特朗普的人在社交媒体上转而攻击他。
Social media-wise, you know I post a lot about Trump since I'm active in this organization and somewhat in the campaign. I've lost a ton of followers, a ton of followers. On Snapchat, a couple hundred. I know that's pretty substantial. I know I've lost about a hundred people on Instagram.
社交媒体方面，你知道我发布了很多关于特朗普的内容，因为我活跃在这个组织里，也在竞选中发挥了一定作用。我损失了大量的粉丝，大量的粉丝。在 Snapchat 上少了有好几百。我知道这相当可观。我知道我在 Instagram 上损失了大约一百人。
Alex is big into Trump. Like, he's making sacrifices. He says he's lost friends. Other black kids at school make fun of him. He's gotten into big fights with his Muslim friends too, like after he posted some anti-Muslim comments from Trump on his Snapchat.
亚历克斯对特朗普很痴迷。就像他正在做出牺牲。他说他失去了朋友。学校里的其他黑人孩子也嘲笑他。他也和他的穆斯林朋友吵过大架，比如在他发布了一些特朗普的反穆斯林言论到他的 Snapchat 上之后。
Last week, one of my Islamic friends asked me, why do you support Trump? And I said I'm not against Islam. I'm not against Muslims. I'm against Islamic extremism. So I'm not against you at all.
上周，我的一位伊斯兰教朋友问我，你为什么支持特朗普？我说我并不反对伊斯兰教。我不反对穆斯林。我反对的是伊斯兰极端主义。所以我根本不反对你。
And she doesn't feel that. She feels like I'm against her. And she said, well, Trump wants to keep out all the Muslims.
她没那种感觉。她觉得我反对她。她说，好吧，特朗普想把所有穆斯林拒之门外。
And I said first off, you're an American citizen. So you have nothing to fear in that regard. We're not going to kick you out of the country. You're an American citizen. You were born here.
我说首先，你是美国公民。所以在这方面你没什么好担心的。我们不会把你赶出这个国家。你是美国公民。你是在这儿出生的。
And then also your parents, who, yes, aren't American citizens, they've given so much to this society. And we don't have to worry about you potentially being part of ISIS or ISIL. There's a very slight chance of that happening.
而且还有你的父母，他们虽然不是美国公民，但他们为这个社会贡献了很多。我们不必担心你可能成为 ISIS 或 ISIL 的一部分。这种可能性微乎其微。
She was annoyed. But they're still friends. Was he afraid of hurting her feelings?
她很生气。但他们还是朋友。他害怕伤害她的感情吗？
Yeah. Yes. I don't want to do that. Yeah. I try to be-- it's like I'm walking on shells because I don't want to break the shells.
是的。是的。我不想那样做。是的。我试着——这就像我在薄冰上行走，因为我不想把冰踩碎。
Alex jumps feet first into Trump-related awkward situations. Like later that day, we walk over to the USC campus. And he flags down college kids walking down the street. He's very formal, like at his most presentational. He's inviting them to this debate watch party he's hosting.
亚历克斯一头扎进了与特朗普有关的尴尬境地。就像那天晚些时候，我们步行到南加州大学校园。他向走在街上的大学生招手。他非常正式，处于他最具有表现力的状态。他邀请他们参加他主办的辩论观看派对。
It's on the 28th. It's the seventh Republican debate. It's going to be huge, as Donald Trump says. So you're more than welcome to come. What is your stance politically?
在 28 号。是第七场共和党辩论。正如唐纳德·特朗普所说，这将会是巨大的。所以非常欢迎你们来。你们的政治立场是什么？
I wouldn't be comfortable having Donald Trump as president. Everything that I've seen through the media, it just comes off he's just full of hate. And I just don't think Donald Trump is very accepting of all people from different backgrounds. And diversity is a huge thing for me personally. But we have to go. But thanks for talking.
如果唐纳德·特朗普当总统，我不会觉得舒服。通过媒体我看到的一切，他给人的感觉充满仇恨。我不认为唐纳德·特朗普非常接受来自不同背景的所有人。多样性对我个人来说是一件大事。但我们要走了。谢谢你们的谈话。
Thank you, ladies.
谢谢，女士们。
How do you think about how that went? Tell me what you think.
你觉得刚才那次谈话怎么样？告诉我你的想法。
I think it went very civilly.
我觉得过程非常文明。
But is it a hard when people your age say to you like, I don't feel comfortable having him as the president because I think he's being racist? Especially when, like, you're black and she's white and she's kind of looking at you, like, hello.
但当和你同龄的人对你说“我觉得他当总统我不舒服，因为我觉得他是种族主义者”时，这很难受吗？特别是在你身为黑人，而她身为白人，她还那种看着你，好像在说“你好吗”的时候。
I don't know. For me, I think they think I'm probably mentally off. That's true. Because I am black and I'm supporting someone that they think is xenophobic or racist.
我不知道。对我来说，我想他们可能认为我脑子有病。是真的。因为我是黑人，而我却在支持一个他们认为是排外或种族主义的人。
So what does it feel like to feel like somebody's looking at you like you're insane?
那么当觉得别人看你就像看疯子一样，是什么感觉？
Really, I just say to myself, well, opinions are opinions. And when Donald J. Trump is president and he reforms this country, I think they will think differently of him.
真的，我只是对自己说，好吧，观点就是观点。当唐纳德·J·特朗普当上总统并改革这个国家时，我想他们会对他有不同的看法。
If Donald Trump was like actually, I don't think that gay marriage is OK and I don't support it, would you still vote for him?
如果唐纳德·特朗普真的说“我不认为同性婚姻没问题，我不支持它”，你还会投他票吗？
He wouldn't do that.
他不会那么做的。
That's a make or break thing for you.
这对你来说是成败的关键吧。
He wouldn't do that, yeah. He wouldn't do that.
他不会那样做的，是的。他不会。
This is officially the strangest reason I'd heard from a Republican about how they'd picked their candidate.
这是我从共和党人那里听到的关于他们如何选择候选人的最奇怪的理由。
The question is there's a whole party, right, the Democratic Party. They're pretty much cool with gay people. Could you just be a Democrat?
问题是有整个政党，对吧，民主党。他们基本上支持同性恋群体。你不能就做个民主党人吗？
My goodness, no.
天哪，不。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
I mean--
我是说——
"Like, are you out of your mind? The choices are between a soon to be indicted liar," Alex says, "and a socialist. I mean, come on."
“就像，你脑子坏了吗？选择是在一个即将被起诉的骗子和一个社会主义者之间，”亚历克斯说，“我是说，得了吧。”
I spent two hours with Alex that day. That was it. We weren't scheduled to meet again.
那天我和亚历克斯待了两个小时。就是这样。我们没有安排再次见面。
Afterward, I went and interviewed other voters, a conservative South Carolina blogger. I drove to Greenville to meet with some morning radio show hosts. But the whole time I was still wondering about Alex. He seemed like he was in the weirdest position of anyone I was meeting, voting for the first time, so young and intense about his beliefs, which just, like, did not match. If gay marriage is your issue, why Trump?
事后，我去采访了其他选民，一位保守派南卡罗来纳州博主。我开车去了格林维尔会见了一些早间广播节目的主持人。但整个时间里，我仍然在想亚历克斯。他似乎处于我见过的任何人中最奇怪的位置，第一次投票，如此年轻且对自己的信仰如此强烈，而这些信仰甚至完全不匹配。如果同性婚姻是你的议题，为什么选特朗普？
Alex told me that church is the center of his family life. And he's in a very conservative evangelical Christian family. He's surrounded by people he loves and respects.
亚历克斯告诉我，教会是他家庭生活的中心。他出身于一个非常保守的福音派基督教家庭。他被他所爱和尊重的人包围着。
I came up with a theory. He was using Trump to reconcile two very irreconcilable things about himself-- deeply conservative, super-gay. Trump, for some reason, is Alex's safe place.
我想出了一个理论。他利用特朗普来调和自身两个极不相容的方面——深度保守、超级同性恋。特朗普，出于某种原因，是亚历克斯的安全港。
I made another appointment with Alex. I had no idea the conversation would lead where it did, which was way beyond Trump.
我跟亚历克斯又约了一次。我不知道谈话会引向哪里，结果远远超出了特朗普。
OK. So we want to ask you a whole bunch of questions.
好的。我们要问你一大堆问题。
OK.
好的。
Some of them are going to be personal.
其中一些会很私人。
I meet him in this conference room at the end of his school day. And every question I ask him, it's like a trap door opens to some deep and dramatic part of his story that I didn't see coming.
在他放学后的会议室里见到他。我问的每一个问题，就像一扇活板门打开，通向他故事中我没预料到的深层戏剧性部分。
Like, first thing, we're still making small talk, settling in. There's this rainbow poster on the wall. He points it out.
比如，一开始，我们还在寒暄，在安顿。墙上有一张彩虹海报。他指了出来。
It's the rainbow.
那是彩虹。
So I ask him, do you have any rainbow stuff? Like what stuff?
所以我问他，你有任何彩虹的东西吗？比如什么东西？
Last year, I was a little bit more bold. Last year was my first year in a public school, a public high school. And it was like-- what was it-- show your character day or something like that. We have these weeks.
去年，我大胆了一点。去年是我在公立学校、公立高中的第一年。就像——是什么来着——展示个性日之类的。我们有这种周活动。
And so I wore a sign that said, guys only apply. Sorry girls, in parentheses, down at the bottom. And it had the rainbow on both sides. And I wore that around the entire school all day long.
所以我戴了一个标语，上面写着“仅限男生申请”。括号里在底部写着“抱歉女生”。两边都有彩虹。我整天在学校里都戴着这个。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
And then people wanted to take pictures with me.
然后人们想和我合影。
Did you leave the house in that shirt?
你穿那件衬衫离开家了吗？
Yes. I did. Because, you see, actually at the time, I wasn't with my parents at the time. So they didn't know about that.
是的。我做了。因为你看，其实当时我没和父母在一起。所以他们不知道那件事。
He was staying with a friend's family for about a month. Things weren't so great at home.
他在朋友家住了一个月。家里情况不太好。
Um, just some family issues, some problems with my dad and stuff.
嗯，只是一些家庭问题，和我爸爸的一些问题之类的。
This was two minutes into our conversation. But it kept happening. Like, I just kept stumbling into these surprising details.
这是我们谈话的第两分钟。但这一直在发生。比如，我一直在撞见这些令人惊讶的细节。
Have you ever been to a Pride parade?
你参加过骄傲游行吗？
No. Well, yes, I have. I have once. It was to protest though. My dad went and took me to protest.
没有。嗯，是的，我有过。我参加过一次。不过是去抗议。我爸爸带我去抗议的。
Then I asked, I know your mom adopted you when she was on her own. So how did she meet your dad?
然后我问，我知道是你妈妈在你单身时收养你的。那么她是怎样认识你爸爸的？
Well, basically what happened is that I needed a manly influence, or that's what some of the elders in our church at the time thought. And so he came into the picture through a connection in our church. And then they fell in love. It was my choice.
嗯，基本上发生的事情是我需要一个男性影响，或者是当时我们教会里的一些长者这么认为的。所以他通过我们教会的一个关系出现在了画面中。然后他们坠入了爱河。这是我的选择。
How was it your choice?
怎么会是你的选择？
She said if I didn't want him as a dad, yeah, she wouldn't make me have someone that wouldn't be good, especially after adopting me.
她说如果我不想要他做爸爸，是的，她不会强迫我接受一个不好的人，尤其是在收养我之后。
Alex's parents are not OK with him being gay. They're evangelical Christians. They believe in the literal word of the Bible and raised Alex that way. But it's also clear that it's a loving home, with this big extended family, who all adore Alex.
亚历克斯的父母不同意他是同性恋。他们是福音派基督徒。他们相信圣经的字面意思，就是这样抚养亚历克斯的。但也明显这是一个充满爱的家庭，有着大家庭，所有人都爱亚历克斯。
Before he was adopted, his life was rough-- foster home, to back with his biological parents, to group home, to foster home. He was really unhappy. But what could he do? He was a kid. And then he met his mom.
在他被领养之前，他的生活很艰难——寄养家庭，回到亲生父母身边，去集体宿舍，再到寄养家庭。他真的很不开心。但他能做什么？他只是个孩子。然后他遇到了他的妈妈。
Alex and his adopted mom are incredibly close. Alex's face just lights up when he talks about her. When he was in third grade, she was his teacher. And then she adopted him. It's almost romantic sounding, like they yearned to be a family as soon as they met.
亚历克斯和他的领养妈妈关系非常亲密。亚历克斯谈到她时脸上总是闪闪发光。他在三年级时，她是他的老师。然后她收养了他。听起来几乎很浪漫，就像他们一见面就渴望成为一家人一样。
But I'd been asking her for about a year, are going to adopt me?
但我已经问过她大约一年了，你要收养我吗？
How did you think to ask that?
你怎么会想到问这个？
I don't know. I've been praying for years to have a mom and a dad. I just connected. It's inaffable.
我不知道。我已经祈祷多年希望能有个妈妈和爸爸。我只是连接上了。这是无法言说的。
Ineffable.
无法言说（Ineffable）。
Ineffable. Thank you. I'm trying to use my new words, ineffable. Yeah, sort of the unspeakable.
无法言说。谢谢。我正试着使用我的新词，无法言说。是的，那种说不出来的。
When Alex's parents found out he was gay, it was as dramatic as things can get in those sort of situations. Alex says they suspected it and read his journal, where he had written about boys. This was in eighth grade. He had to leave school immediately and his parents started homeschooling him. And they brought in their church.
当亚历克斯的父母发现他是同性恋时，在那类情况下这非常戏剧化。亚历克斯说他们怀疑了，并读了他的日记，上面写着关于男孩的事。那是八年级。他不得不立即退学，父母开始让他进行在家教育。他们带入了他们的教会。
And they wanted to nip this in the bud. Snap, cut it, make sure I was straight. And I was like a-- yeah. So the clergy came down, sat with me, the elders and people. And they read from scripture and everything.
他们想把这扼杀在摇篮里。掐断，切断，确保我是直的。我当时就像——是的。所以神职人员来了，和我坐在一起，长者们和人们。他们读了经文，诸如此类。
And I was just sitting there quietly. At first I saw it as like, oh, my goodness. This is a sin. I can't believe this. I'm going to go hell. Oh, my god, I'm going to burn in hell for all eternity.
我只是安静地坐在那儿。起初我把它看作是，哦，天哪。这是罪。我不敢相信。我要下地狱了。噢，天哪，我要在地狱里永恒地燃烧。
And so they're reading from scripture. And they're saying, this is what the scripture says, man shall not lie with another man, whatever. And the more that happened, the harder I became. I was less soft. And then my mom got a therapist for me, another one, a different one, for me being gay.
所以他们正在读经文。他们说，这就是经文说的，男人不得与男人同寝，无论如何。这种情况发生得越多，我就越坚硬。我没那么软弱了。然后我妈妈为我请了一位治疗师，又一位，不同的一个，针对我身为同性恋。
Was this one of those therapists who is like, I'm going to help you be not gay?
这是那些声称“我会帮你变得不是同性恋”的治疗师之一吗？
Yeah. He was a preacher [LAUGHS] with the Presbyterian therapists' organization. He didn't do anything. I just told him I'm gay. I said this is what's going to happen. I'm gay. But you can talk about how I can have a better relationship with my parents.
是的。他是一位传教士[笑]，属于长老会治疗师组织。他什么也没做。我只是告诉他我是同性恋。我说这就是现实。我是同性恋。但你可以谈谈我如何能与父母有更好的关系。
I have a theory, sort of. It's not really a theory. But I'm wondering it.
我有一个理论，某种程度上。这不是真正的理论。但我很纳闷。
OK.
好的。
I'm wondering if a major reason that you're supporting Donald Trump so hard, that you're going in so hard for Trump, is because it's a way to express that you're gay, that that matters to you, and still keep your tie with being a Republican? Because you've grown up around all Republicans and being a conservative is a big part of your upbringing.
我纳闷你如此用力地支持唐纳德·特朗普，你如此用力地投入特朗普，是不是因为这是一种表达你身为同性恋、这事对你很重要，同时又保持你身为共和党人的联系的方式？因为你是伴随着共和党人长大的，身为保守派是你成长过程中很重要的一部分。
Yeah. I wouldn't 100 percent disagree with that. I guess you would say that. It is a way for me to still accept me for being gay. However, I can still hold to my Republican principles, some of my Republican principles, without hurting my own people. That's why I couldn't support Cruz.
是的。我不会百分之百不同意这一点。我想你可以这么说。这是我保持接纳自己作为同性恋的一种方式。然而，我仍然可以坚持我的共和党原则，我的一些共和党原则，而不伤害我的人民。这就是为什么我不能支持克鲁兹。
Alex's parents are big Cruz supporters. I asked if they'd talk to me about Alex. They agreed. This his mom, Jan Chalgren.
亚历克斯的父母是克鲁兹的大力支持者。我问他们是否愿意谈谈亚历克斯。他们同意了。这是他的妈妈，简·查尔格伦。
I don't see his participating in a gay life as God's plan for his life. I firmly believe that.
我不认为他参与同性恋生活是上帝对他生活的计划。我坚定地相信这一点。
Jane didn't want to get into detail about what happened when she and her husband figured out Alex was gay. But she did talk about what it was like for her.
简不想详细说明当她和丈夫发现亚历克斯是同性恋时发生了什么。但她确实谈到了这对她来说是什么感觉。
Heartbreaking, when that's not what I wanted for him. And I don't believe that's what God desires for him either. I love him. I love him to death and will always, always. And my husband and I have both told him that. We will always love you. We don't agree.
心碎，当那不是我想要他的样子。我也不认为那是上帝希望他有的样子。我爱他。我爱他爱得要死，并且永远、永远都会爱。我和我丈夫都告诉过他。我们永远爱你。我们不同意。
You don't agree with which?
不同意什么？
With gay marriage. Yeah.
同性婚姻。是的。
She has the same feeling Alex has. It hurts to be disagreeing about anything because they're so connected. She has the same feelings about meeting Alex that he does about meeting her.
她和亚历克斯有同样的感受。对于任何事情持不同意见都很痛苦，因为他们联系太紧密了。她对遇见亚历克斯的感觉和他对遇见她的感觉一样。
Well, one day in November, it was '07, the Secretary of the school knocked on my door and said I have a new student for you, a total surprise. And it was Alex, with his foster mom. And I brought him in and got him a desk. And a cute little thing, with his little glasses.
好吧，11 月的一天，那是 07 年，学校秘书敲我的门说我有一个新学生给你，一个大惊喜。那是亚历克斯，和他的寄养妈妈一起。我把他带进来，给了他一张桌子。可爱的小东西，戴着眼镜。
And as time went on, he just captured my heart. He can carry on a conversation easily with any age person. And he always wanted to talk with me.
随着时间的推移，他捕捉了我的心。他可以轻松地与任何年龄的人进行对话。他总是想和我谈话。
Did you ever anticipate adopting some kid from your class?
你有没有想过领养班上的某个孩子？
I never anticipated, never planned for it, never thought. No. But really, he had my heart. And I went through the adoption process. And then we started visits.
我从没预料到，没计划过，没想过。不。但真的，他拥有了我的心。然后我经历了领养程序。然后我们开始了互访。
They'd never spent time together outside of the classroom. So Alex proposed going to church together.
他们从没在课堂外在一起过。所以亚历克斯提议一起去教堂。
And we did that several times. And then I was able to bring him to my house for a visit. And I remember him standing in the kitchen, looking at me and saying, "do you think about adopting me?" And I pretty much had to say, "well, we're going to pray about that. You and I together cannot talk about that. But I'm talking to your social worker. And we'll just pray and see what the Lord does."
我们那样做了好几次。然后我能带他到我家访问。我记得他站在厨房里，看着我说：“你有没有想过收养我？”我差不多得说：“好吧，我们要为此祈祷。你和我不能谈这个。但我正在和你的社会工作者谈。我们要祈祷看看主怎么做。”
And the Lord led our hearts together. He put our family together. And it's been wonderful. It's been difficult.
主把我们的心引导在一起。他把我们的家庭组合在一起。这很美妙。这很难。
Alex, in his coming out process, I think, didn't want to lose his connection to Christianity. Eventually, in a way that I now think of as typically Alex, this eternal optimist way, he figured out a way to be gay and be a born again Christian. He reconciled these two things that seemed irreconcilable.
亚历克斯，在他的出柜过程中，我想，不想失去他与基督教的联系。最终，以我称之为典型的亚历克斯的方式，那种永恒乐观主义者的方式，他找到了一种身为同性恋又是重生基督徒的方式。他调和了这两个似乎 irreconcilable（不相容）的事情。
He looked up this alternative interpretation of the story of Sodom and Gomorrah and found a way that the scripture itself legitimized gay relationships. And he felt better. He could be both, gay and Christian. Jan says despite everything they've tried, the therapy, the homeschooling, the ministering--
他查阅了对所多玛和蛾摩拉故事的替代诠释，找到了一种圣经本身使同性恋关系合法化的方式。他感觉好多了。他可以既是同性恋又是基督徒。简说尽管他们尝试了一切，治疗，家庭教育，传教——
He has continued with being very pleased over the political climate. When states approve gay marriage, he will post, yay.
他继续对政治气候非常满意。当各州批准同性婚姻时，他会发帖说，耶。
How do you feel about that?
你怎么看？
Oh. My hope is in the Lord. There's nothing that the Lord can't recover. Nothing he can't redeem.
噢。我的希望在主里。没有什么主不能恢复的。没有什么他不能救赎的。
You know, he's 18 now. He's of age. The first thing he did when turned 18, the day he turned 18, he went out and registered to vote. That's something. I mean that is something.
你知道，他现在 18 岁了。他成年了。他 18 岁做的第一件事，就在他满 18 岁的那天，他出去登记投票了。那是一回事。我是说那是一回事。
It's Alex's dad though, Ted Chalgren, that's the major Cruz supporter in the family. Alex told me he sees Cruz as the most hardline against gay marriage and the most dangerous because he has experience arguing in front of the Supreme Court. So Cruz is the one guy who makes Alex the maddest. And Alex's dad knows that.
不过，是亚历克斯的爸爸，泰德·查尔格伦，是家里主要的克鲁兹支持者。亚历克斯告诉我他认为克鲁兹是对同性婚姻最强硬、最危险的人，因为他有在最高法院辩论的经验。所以克鲁兹是让亚历克斯最生气的人。而亚历克斯的爸爸知道这一点。
What Cruz says is he's for the traditional family. And I guess that's enough of a red flag for the people who embrace the other position, that he's out and the fact that we embrace that. But he knows that. I mean we embrace a man and a woman. And, yeah, I'm sure he feels some rejection. And then that probably solidified it.
克鲁兹所说的是他支持传统家庭。我想这对于那些拥抱另一种立场的人来说是一个足够的危险信号，他出柜了，而我们拥抱那个事实。但他知道这一点。我是说我们拥抱男人和女人。而且，是的，我相信他感到了一些排斥。然后这可能巩固了它。
What was it like, if you can give me one example, when you found out he was gay?
是什么感觉，如果能举个例子，当你知道他是同性恋时？
Oh. It made me so angry because I am vehemently opposed to that. Now, I have gay acquaintances, even in my work. I mean I just love them. I try to reach out to them and I fail.
噢。它让我非常生气，因为我强烈反对那个。现在，我有同性恋熟人，甚至在工作中。我是说我只是爱他们。我试着接触他们，但我失败了。
It just really angered me. It broke my heart. It broke my heart for him because I think he has opened up a Pandora's box of real trouble for himself. One of the concerns, not the primary concern, is sexually transmitted diseases. And what are they called, STDs. That really is a concern.
它真的让我很生气。它伤了我的心。它为他伤了我的心，因为我想他为自己打开了一个真正麻烦的潘多拉魔盒。关切之一，不是主要的关切，是性传播疾病。它们叫什么，STDs。那真的是一个关切。
Another concern for Ted is suicide rates for gay men. So he confronted Alex with his stats.
泰德的另一个关切是同性恋男性的自杀率。所以他用数据质问亚历克斯。
And he could counter every one. He had done his research. He could counter all those. Well, in the general population, you know, yada, yada. And so none of that worked. And I was really angry. I would get angry with him quicker about other things just because I'd had this brooding anger at him about that.
而他可以反驳每一个。他做过研究。他可以反驳所有那些。好吧，在一般人群中，你知道，诸如此类。所以这些都没用。我真的很生气。我会比其他事情更快地对他生气，只因为我对他有这种积压的愤怒。
And he ran away. He's run away three or four times. One time he stayed away for some weeks. And actually he jumped out of the car when I was driving and ran. He said, let me out of here.
他跑了。他跑了三四次。有一次他离开了几周。事实上，在我开车时他跳下车跑了。他说，让我出去。
What were you guys talking about? Do you remember?
你们在谈论什么？你记得吗？
He was going-- he wanted to apply for this job.
他正在——他想申请这份工作。
This was a year and a half ago. Things were so tense between them anything could become a big fight. Alex had been offered a job at Hollister, a clothing store at the mall his dad describes as wild.
这是一年半前的事了。他们之间的气氛非常紧张，任何事情都可能变成一场大争吵。亚历克斯曾被霍利斯特公司聘用，那是一家商场里的服装店，他爸爸称之为狂野。
And I didn't want him work at that place because I wanted him-- because it was over at the mall. I said, I'm not taking you to interview over there. You need to go over here and get a bag boy job at Publix or go down here to Babham's Feed and Seed and get a job down there toting feed and seed, if they'll hire you. Because you need to get a job for which you don't require transportation.
我不想让他在那儿工作，因为我不想他——因为那是在商场那边。我说，我不带你去那边面试。你需要到这边来，在 Publix 找个包装工的工作，或者到这儿的 Babham's Feed and Seed 找个搬运饲料和种子的工作，如果他们雇用你的话。因为你需要找一份不需要交通工具的工作。
Do you see what I'm saying? It needs to be walkable. But he had-- high-falutin'. So anyway, he jumped out of the car because I said, "no, I'm not taking you there." And he said something else. "So that's way it's going to be?" I said, "absolutely."
你明白我的意思吗？它需要是可步行的。但他——自视甚高。总之，他跳下了车，因为我说：“不，我不带你去那儿。”他又说了别的。“所以这就是要发生的方式？”我说，“绝对。”
He said, "I want out. Pull over." And I wasn't going to let him order me to pull over. You don't order your dad to do something. He said, "I want out." And he started-- so I slowed down. He bailed.
他说：“我要出去。靠边停车。”我不会让他命令我靠边停车的。你不能命令你爸爸做某事。他说：“我要出去。”他开始——所以我减速了。他跳车了。
So there's been some of that combat at home, the real intense sort of combative, you could cut the environment with a knife. It really started with that coming out, isn't that what they call it? And Jan and I prayed about it. We wept about it.
所以家里发生了一些冲突，真正激烈的那种斗争，那种可以用刀切开环境的冲突。它真的是从那个出柜开始的，他们不是这么叫吗？简和我为此祈祷。我们为此哭泣。
I just sort of-- I think the Lord just jumped over my heart. I said let's just have peace at home. So we have peace at home.
我只是有点——我想主只是跳过了我的心。我说让我们在家里和平相处吧。所以我们家里很和平。
Right now, with the election season, in the Chalgren household, there is something new to talk about. Now, he and his parents debate over Cruz versus Trump, instead of gay, not gay. Though the conversation sounds kind of similar, it is less painful.
现在，随着选举季节，在查尔格伦家，有了新的谈话内容。现在，他和父母辩论克鲁兹对决特朗普，而不是同性恋、非同性恋。尽管谈话听起来有点相似，但没那么痛苦。
I delight in the victories and the things that Ted Cruz says, the principles and standards he has. So Alex knows that. And I know he's supporting Trump.
我享受泰德·克鲁兹所说的胜利和事情，他所拥有的原则和标准。所以亚历克斯知道这一点。我知道他支持特朗普。
I've sort of had the hope that this is just a fantasy for him or maybe a fancy, however you want to say that. And he is very gracious with regard to not rubbing in to me the fact that Donald Trump is 800 points ahead of Ted Cruz in all the polls. He's not in my face. He's not.
我有点希望这对他来说只是一个幻想，或者说是狂想，无论你如何称呼它。而且他非常有礼貌，不把唐纳德·特朗普在所有民调中领先泰德·克鲁兹 800 点的事实拿来挖苦我。他没在我的脸上。他没有。
And so I don't get too thrilled in front of him about what he's doing. But I'm really proud of him. And I'm really sort of dazzled by how successfully he engages his endeavors and so often accomplishes his goals.
所以我没在他面前对他所做的事情感到太激动。但我真的为他感到骄傲。而且我真的有点被他如何成功地从事他的事业并经常实现他的目标所震撼。
So detente. Alex's dad had a strong Christian candidate. Alex had a candidate whom he believed supported gay marriage. Everyone was getting along. And then right as we were having these conversations, this happened. Trump went on TV and talked about the Supreme Court ruling on gay marriage.
所以缓和。亚历克斯的爸爸有一个强大的基督教候选人。亚历克斯有一个他相信支持同性婚姻的候选人。每个人都相处得很好。然后就在我们进行这些谈话时，发生了这件事。特朗普上电视谈论最高法院关于同性婚姻的裁决。
But I would have much preferred that they ruled at a state level and allowed the states to make those rulings themselves.
但我更希望他们是在州一级做出裁决，并允许各州自己做出这些裁决。
But just to button up this up very quickly, sir. Are you saying that if you become president, you might try to appoint justices to overrule the decision on same sex marriage?
但先生，为了迅速结束这个话题，你是说如果你当选总统，你可能会尝试任命法官来推翻关于同性婚姻的决定吗？
I would strongly consider that. Yes.
我会强烈考虑这一点。是的。
It was too obvious now. This thing Alex said would never happen, this thing he'd said mattered so much to him, the reason he'd staked himself on Trump in the first place, it just didn't seem true. So I sat Alex down and asked about it.
这现在太明显了。亚历克斯说永远不会发生的这件事，他说对自己很重要的这件事，他最初将自己赌在特朗普身上的原因，看起来根本不真实。所以我让亚历克斯坐下来问了他。
What does it feel like when he says something like that?
当他说那样的话时是什么感觉？
It doesn't feel anything to me. He's saying those sort of things to get the votes. And I understand that. And gay marriage, it's done. It's done. There's no reversing it.
我没有任何感觉。他是为了选票才说那种话的。我理解这一点。而且同性婚姻，已经结束了。已经完成了。没有逆转的余地。
But Donald Trump, he's just saying it to say it because he needs to get the votes. He's saying that if he could appoint justices to fix this ruling, he would. I support Trump fully. I support Trump fully.
但唐纳德·特朗普，他只是为了说而说，因为他需要选票。他说如果他能任命法官来修复这个裁决，他会。我完全支持特朗普。我完全支持特朗普。
So maybe is it possible that I sort of overestimated how important the gay rights stance was for you with the Republican candidate you had picked?
所以也许有可能我高估了同性恋权利立场对你选择共和党候选人的重要性吗？
Here's the thing. I'm not selfish. At least I don't think I'm selfish. And so it would be selfish for me to risk the entire survival of our country off of gay marriage.
事情是这样的。我不是自私的。至少我不认为我是自私的。所以如果我为了同性婚姻而冒着我们国家彻底灭亡的风险，那将是自私的。
There was something else I noticed talking to Alex this time around, something a little different with him. He was so much more into Trump, even than he had been two weeks ago. It was like his favorite football team was in the Super Bowl or something. He was just googly-eyed for him. His reasons for supporting Trump no longer came from reasoning out one position to the next. It was more chemical, emotional.
这次和亚历克斯谈话，我还注意到了别的东西，他身上有些不同的东西。他比两周前还要更迷特朗普。就像他最喜欢的橄榄球队进入了超级碗一样。他看着他时眼里全是小星星。他支持特朗普的理由不再来源于从一个立场推论到另一个立场。它更化学、更情绪化。
I like his persona. I like his stance on domestic policy in regard to building the wall, and building up our security, and his financial policy. I like it. I agree with it.
我喜欢他的个性。我喜欢他在国内政策上的立场，关于建墙，建立我们的安全，以及他的财政政策。我喜欢它。我同意它。
That we need to crush ISIS. We need to deal with the problem. We need to get rid of the problem.
我们需要粉碎 ISIS。我们需要处理这个问题。我们需要摆脱这个问题。
You see how I do my hands here?
你看到我这儿是怎么用手的吗？
Yeah.
是的。
That's like Trump. He does this.
那就像特朗普。他做这个。
Alex, you've probably figured out by now, fits into no known category of voter. All the ways that reporters and political consultants slice up populations, they don't apply to him.
亚历克斯，你大概现在已经发现了，不适合任何已知的选民类别。记者和政治顾问划分人群的所有方式，对他都不适用。
He's not voting like a black voter, or a young voter, or a Christian voter, or a gay voter, or a Southern voter. But, of course, the way we choose our candidates is not a science. It's this alchemical mix of where we grew up, and who we respect, and whether we woke up this morning and were full of hope or full of fear.
他投票不像黑人选民，或年轻选民，或基督教选民，或同性恋选民，或南方选民。但当然，我们选择候选人的方式不是一门科学。它是我们成长的地方、我们尊重谁、以及我们今天早上醒来时是充满希望还是充满恐惧的炼金术混合物。
And with Trump, maybe with any outsider candidate, Sanders or 2008 Obama, there seem to be so many idiosyncratic personal journeys that lead supporters to him. In New Hampshire, Trump won men. He won women. He won the young people and the old people, people who live in cities and in the country.
而对于特朗普，也许对于任何局外候选人，桑德斯或 2008 年的奥巴马，似乎有太多的个人特性旅程引导支持者走向他。在新罕布什尔州，特朗普赢得了男性。他赢得了女性。他赢得了年轻人和老年人，住在城市和乡村的人。
There is this other thing that both Alex's parents said to me separately when I asked why their son was into Trump? They said Trump's campaign reached out to Alex, remember. Alex liked that.
还有另外一件事，当我问为什么他们的儿子迷特朗普时，亚历克斯的父母分别对我说。他们说特朗普的竞选团队接触了亚历克斯，记得吗。亚历克斯喜欢那样。
He really wants to be a political organizer. They think if Rubio's campaign had called, he might be working for Rubio right now. And the reason he liked Trump, they both said, was something much deeper about Alex, something I didn't see on my own. But they did.
他真的想成为一名政治组织者。他们认为如果卢比奥的竞选团队打过电话，他现在可能就在为卢比奥工作了。而且他们都说，他喜欢特朗普的原因是关于亚历克斯更深层的东西，我自己没看到的东西。但他们看到了。
Because Trump shows power and Alex is about power. Because he was so impotent as a child, he had no control over his life.
因为特朗普展现了权力，而亚历克斯追求的是权力。因为他作为一个孩子太无能了，他对自己的生活没有任何控制权。
There's something powerful about Donald Trump. And that appeals to Alex. When he speaks about his future, I think he pictures himself living like Donald Trump, with a penthouse on the 77th floor of something. And he's told Jan and I that we're going to live with him on his ranch. He's going to have horses and thousands of acres.
唐纳德·特朗普身上有一些强大的东西。这吸引了亚历克斯。当他谈到他的未来时，我想他想象自己像唐纳德·特朗普一样生活，在某物的 77 楼有顶层公寓。而且他告诉简和我，我们要在他的牧场和他一起生活。他要养马，有几千英亩土地。
When I talked to Alex most recently, after talking to his parents, this was the thing that made the most sense, the power vote.
当我最近与亚历克斯交谈，在与他父母交谈之后，这是最有意义的事情，权力投票。
And you can ask my mom this, ask my dad this. I have this sort of like gravitating pull towards people who are successful because I too want to be successful. Yeah. I want to be-- not necessarily, I don't focus on wealth. I focus on power. Because as Kevin Spacey said, in House of Cards, a fool goes after money. But someone that really seeks to control goes after power.
你可以问我妈妈这一点，问我爸爸这一点。我有一种引力吸引向成功的人，因为我也想成功。是的。我想成为——不一定，我不关注财富。我关注权力。因为正如凯文·史派西在《纸牌屋》中所说，傻瓜追求金钱。但真正寻求控制的人追求权力。
The power vote, those who want more power than they feel they have right now. That is a lot of people for a lot of reasons. That is the category Alex falls into now. The power vote-- that's Alex Chalgren.
权力投票，那些想要比他们现在感觉拥有的更多权力的人。那是很多人，出于很多原因。这就是亚历克斯现在落入的类别。权力投票——那就是亚历克斯·查尔格伦。
Zoe Chace. She's one of the producers of our show. Coming up, what if you could save thousands of lives each year doing something that most people find morally repugnant? That's in a minute from Chicago Public Radio, when our program continues.
佐伊·蔡斯。她是我们的制作人之一。接下来，如果你能做大多数人觉得道德上令人厌恶的事情而每年挽救成千上万条生命，那会怎么样？一分钟后从芝加哥公共广播电台，当我们的节目继续时。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Each week on our program, of course, we choose a theme. Today's theme, That's One Way to Do It-- stories of people making choices, the people near to them do not expect. We've arrived at Act Two of our program.
这是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。我们节目每周当然会选择一个主题。今天的主题是《那是一种方法》——人们做出他们身边人没预料到的选择的故事。我们已经到达了节目的第二幕。
Act Two, Here's Looking at You, Kidney.
第二幕，看着你，肾脏。
Of course, the main reason that we try unexpected things is when the old things do not work-- necessity, mother of invention, et cetera, et cetera. This next story is about something that definitely is not working as well as it could. It's something that results in tens of thousands of American lives lost each year. Stephanie Foo explains.
当然，我们尝试意想不到的事情的主要原因是当旧的事情不奏效时——必要性，发明之母，等等等等。下一个故事是关于一些绝对没有达到应有效果的事情。它是每年导致成千上万美国人生命丧失的事情。斯蒂芬妮·富解释。
Here's something you'd think they'd make easy, but instead it's pretty hard-- donating a kidney. In 2009, Sigrid Fry-Revere learned just how hard.
这是一件你会认为他们会让它变得容易的事情，但相反它很难——捐献肾脏。 2009 年，西格丽德·弗莱-里维尔了解到了它有多难。
Her friend Maurie's kidney was failing. He needed a transplant. And he's someone who knew the system. He actually worked at the National Kidney Foundation of Michigan. So he knew his chances of getting a kidney were slim because there were over a hundred thousand people on the waiting list for kidneys.
她朋友莫里的肾脏正在衰竭。他需要移植。而且他是一个了解系统的人。他实际上在密歇根州国家肾脏基金会工作。所以他知道他得到肾脏的机会很渺茫，因为等待肾脏名单上有超过十万人。
So I know this sounds weird. But I just knew if I gave Maurie a kidney, he'd take good care of it. It would be going to someone that I'd grown to love and care about. And I offered to donate to him. I said, I'll help you. And there was just silence on the phone.
所以我知道这听起来很奇怪。但我只是知道如果我给莫里一个肾，他会好好照顾它的。它会传给一个我成长中爱和关心的人。我提议捐给他。我说，我会帮助你。电话里一片寂静。
Obviously, he was just totally flabbergast. And thanked me. And I said, well, let's get the ball rolling.
显然，他完全惊呆了。并感谢我。我说，好吧，让球滚动起来吧。
So Sigrid began the process every kidney donor has to go through. She contacted a transplant hospital, which coordinated the donation. There were months of blood tests and paperwork and phone calls.
所以西格丽德开始了每个肾脏捐献者必须经历的过程。她联系了一家移植医院，协调捐献。有几个月的验血、文书工作和电话。
I had to do everything. And when I would talk to Maurie about it, he would say, I can't help you because they really want to make sure I'm not pressuring you into doing this.
我必须做每一件事。当我与莫里谈论它时，他会说，我不能帮助你，因为他们真的想确保我没有强迫你做这件事。
Finally, after six months, she had a conference call with a panel from the transplant hospital, a final screening about her decision to donate. They had a lot of questions for her. But one of the biggest was, what's going to happen to your farm?
终于，六个月后，她与移植医院的一个小组进行了电话会议，关于她捐献决定的最后筛选。他们问了她很多问题。但其中最大的一个是，你的农场会发生什么？
Sigrid lives on a farm and had animals that needed taking care of -- donkeys to feed, water to haul. So she'd arranged for her husband and son to each take a couple weeks off, which would give her a month of recovery time. But the panel said she might need longer than that.
西格丽德住在农场，有需要照顾的动物——要喂驴，要运水。所以她安排了丈夫和儿子每人休两周假，这将给她一个月的康复时间。但小组说她可能需要更长的时间。
And so when I said "I don't know. I mean maybe I could hire a part-time farmhand, maybe Maurie could help me." And that was the red flag. They said, "he can't do that."
所以当我说是“我不知道。我是说也许我可以雇一个兼职农场工人，也许莫里可以帮我。”那是危险信号。他们说，“他不能那样做。”
And I said "oh, oh, OK. What should we do then?" And they said, well, "we're going to have to deny your request to donate to Maurie." And I'm like pleading on the phone. I'm crying. I'm pleading.
我说“噢，噢，好的。那我们该怎么办？”他们说，好吧，“我们将不得不拒绝你捐给莫里的请求。”我在电话里恳求。我哭了。我在恳求。
I'm saying, "well, wait a minute. Give me more time. Give me more time. We can figure something out, can't we?"
我说，“好吧，等等。给我更多时间。给我更多时间。我们可以弄清楚，不是吗？”
I mean, at this point it had been over six months of processing my application. And then here they are on the phone, telling me, in five minutes, sorry.
我是说，此时已经超过六个月的处理我的申请。然后他们在这儿电话里，在五分钟内告诉我，对不起。
Sigrid went and reread the law that governs these things, the National Organ Transplant Act. It says recipients can help donors out by paying them out-of-pocket for lodging, and transportation, and lost wages, but nothing else. So if Maurie gave Sigrid a few thousand dollars to hire someone to help around Sigrid's property while she recovered, that would be considered kidney trafficking. The punishment would be up to five years in prison and a $50,000 fine.
西格丽德去重读了管辖这些事情的法律，《国家器官移植法》。它说接受者可以通过支付食宿、交通和损失工资来帮助捐献者，但不能支付别的。所以如果莫里给西格丽德几千美元雇人帮助她在恢复期间处理她的财产，那会被认为是肾脏走私。惩罚将是最高五年监禁和五万美元罚款。
The hardest call I ever made-- I mean this quite seriously-- was calling Maurie and saying [SIGHS] they said no. We started over. But then he developed a heart condition.
我打过最难的一通电话——我是真心这样说的——是打给莫里说[叹气]他们说不。我们重新开始。但后来他患上了心脏病。
It's common for people who have been on dialysis for a long time to get heart conditions. Maurie's heart got so weak he was no longer eligible for a new kidney.
长期透析的人患心脏病很常见。莫里的心脏变得太弱，不再有资格获得新肾脏。
You're talking three or four months later. So if the transplant had gone ahead, he might still be alive today. And I should have lied.
你谈论的是三四个月后。所以如果移植进行了，他今天可能还活着。我应该撒谎的。
I should not have told them that Maurie was willing to help me with the farmhand expenses. Or I shouldn't have mentioned that my family members could only help out for a month. What I heard from other transplant patients, they just don't mention that money is going to pass between the donor and the recipient.
我不应该告诉他们莫里愿意帮我支付农场工人的费用。或者我不应该提到我的家庭成员只能帮忙一个月。我从其他移植病人那里听到的是，他们只是不提到钱会在捐献者和接受者之间传递。
The average wait for a kidney is five years. Most patients on dialysis never get one and die within those five years.
肾脏平均等待时间是五年。大多数透析患者永远拿不到，并在那五年内死亡。
This wasn't Sigrid's first experience with our kidney donation system. When Sigrid's son was 10 months old, he lost a kidney to cancer. He's now in his 20s and functioning just fine on his one healthy kidney. But for several years, doctors worried that he might need a transplant.
这不是西格丽德第一次经历我们的肾脏捐献系统。当西格丽德的儿子 10 个月大时，他因癌症失去了一个肾脏。他现在 20 多岁，用他那一个健康的肾脏功能运转良好。但几年里，医生担心他可能需要移植。
That concern led Sigrid to begin studying organ donation. And she eventually even became a medical ethicist. And in the 30 years she's been studying organ donation since then, she says she's seen how ineffective and even counterproductive our system can be.
那种关切导致西格丽德开始学习器官捐献。她最终甚至成为了一名医学伦理学家。在她学习器官捐献的 30 年里，她说她看到了我们的系统有多么低效，甚至是适得其反。
Our huge kidney shortage doesn't make a lot of sense because, unlike hearts and lungs, there's no shortage of healthy kidneys, pumping away in most of us, primed for donation. We all have a secret power, kind of like how a starfish can grow a new arm. If you remove one of our kidneys, the remaining kidney grows by as much as 50% so it can take on the work of its missing partner.
我们巨大的肾脏短缺意义不大，因为不像心脏和肺，健康的肾脏并不短缺，在我们大多数人身上泵送，为捐献做好准备。我们都有秘密力量，有点像海星怎么能长出新手臂。如果你切除我们一个肾脏，剩下的肾脏长到 50%，这样它就能承担起丢失伙伴的工作。
So as far as something requiring major abdominal surgery goes, kidney donation is very safe. And yet a hundred thousand people are sitting on the kidney transplant waiting list. Each year, only a tiny portion of them, just 15%, get a kidney.
所以关于需要大型腹部手术的事情，肾脏捐献是非常安全的。然而十万人坐在肾脏移植等待名单上。每年，只有一小部分，仅 15%，得到肾脏。
Sigrid thought there had to be better answers out there. There had to be a way to get more people to donate their kidneys. So she set up a panel where she worked, at the Cato Institute.
西格丽德认为外面肯定有更好的答案。肯定有办法让更多人捐献肾脏。所以她在工作的地方，卡托研究所，设立了一个小组。
Welcome to Cato. I am the director of bioethics studies here at Cato.
欢迎来到卡托。我是这里卡托的生物伦理研究主任。
And at this panel, this nephrologist, a.k.a. a kidney doctor, named Benjamin Hippen, he started talking about something that seemed almost too good to be true, a country that had solved their organ crisis. They had a waiting list of people who wanted to donate-- too many donors.
在这个小组上，这位肾脏学家，也就是肾脏医生，名叫本杰明·希彭，他开始谈论一些似乎好得难以置信的事情，一个解决了器官危机的国家。他们有一份想要捐献的人的等待名单——捐献者太多了。
And what you're going to hear today is what lessons can be learned from what's been reported in peer-reviewed journals from a number of different transplant centers in Iran.
今天你们将听到的是，从伊朗许多不同移植中心在同行评审期刊上报道的内容中，可以吸取什么经验。
Yep, Iran. Except, Dr. Hippen explained, the way Iran accomplished this was by doing something no other country in the world allows. In Iran, you can buy a kidney from someone else. And it's legal.
没错，伊朗。除了，希彭医生解释说，伊朗实现这一目标的方式是做了一件世界上没有任何其他国家允许的事情。在伊朗，你可以从别人那里买肾。而且它是合法的。
Half the panel hated the idea. An organ donation policy guy, Sam Crowe, said there are just some things you don't want to let people buy and sell.
小组的一半讨厌这个想法。器官捐献政策人，萨姆·克罗，说有些事情你就是不想让人们买卖。
This might sound crass. But the same could be said for child pornography. The same could be said for the sex slave trade. I mean these are kinds of things that we outlaw because we're going to have a civil society.
这听起来可能粗俗。但同样的说法也适用于儿童色情。同样的说法也适用于性奴贸易。我是说这些是我们取缔的事情，因为我们要有一个文明社会。
Well done.
做得好。
I'm now provoked. You got me.
我现在被激怒了。你抓住我了。
So we can say that this has anything to do with what we're being proposed. Child pornography has nothing to do with what we're proposing today. We're proposing a situation to solve a terrible problem for out patients.
所以我们可以说这和我们正在提议的事情有任何关系。儿童色情和我们今天提议的事情毫无关系。我们提议的是一个解决病人可怕问题的局面。
The debate essentially degenerated into what is going on in Iran. And no one had been there. And no one knew what was going on. So the whole debate was, I know better than you what's happening there. And no Westerner had really studied the Iranian system.
辩论本质上退化为伊朗正在发生什么。没人去过那里。没人知道那里正在发生什么。所以整个辩论是，我知道的比你知道那里正在发生什么。而且没有西方人真正研究过伊朗的系统。
So I was actually kind of angry. I said, well, isn't the answer to what's going on in Iran to go see what's going on in Iran?
所以我当时其实有点生气。我说，嗯，伊朗正在发生什么的答案不是去看看伊朗正在发生什么吗？
So did you think that paying donors might work?
所以你认为支付捐献者可能有效？
Yes. I thought if it's true, how did they do it and did they do it in an ethical way? And if they did do it in an ethical way, my god, we had an answer. Or we could improve on whatever Iran was doing, emulate some of what they were doing in a better way. After all, we're America, right?
是的。我想如果那是真的，他们是怎么做到的，他们是以合乎道德的方式做到的吗？如果他们真的以合乎道德的方式做到，我的天，我们有了一个答案。或者我们可以改进伊朗正在做的任何事情，在更好的方式下模仿他们正在做的一些事情。毕竟，我们是美国，对吧？
Sigrid wanted to go to Iran herself and conduct her own research on how Iran's living donor system worked. She presented this idea to her bosses at Cato, a libertarian think tank. So you think they'd like the idea of unleashing the power of free markets on organ donation. But this was in 2008, when Iran was still firmly a member of the axis of evil. Cato told her, no way. So Sigrid quit and began to plan her trip.
西格丽德想自己去伊朗，对伊朗活体捐献系统是如何运作的进行自己的研究。她向她在卡托的雇主、一个自由意志主义智库提出了这个想法。所以你以为他们会喜欢释放自由市场在器官捐献上的力量的想法。但这是在 2008 年，当时伊朗仍然坚定地是邪恶轴心成员。卡托告诉她，没门。所以西格丽德辞职并开始计划她的行程。
In November, 2008, Sigrid and an Iranian-American nephrologist, named Dr. Bajar Bastani, arrived in Iran. They interviewed hundreds of people-- doctors, people who worked donation centers, and, of course, donors and recipients.
2008 年 11 月，西格丽德和一位名叫巴贾·巴斯塔尼的伊朗裔美国肾脏学家抵达伊朗。他们采访了数百人——医生、在捐献中心工作的人，当然还有捐献者和接受者。
Sigrid learned that there are certain rules that everyone in Iran must abide by. Both the donor and the recipient have to be Iranian citizens, for instance. But beyond that, it's practiced differently from province to province, depending on where you are. And what Sigrid saw at first was pretty disturbing.
西格丽德了解到，伊朗每个人都必须遵守某些规则。例如，捐献者和接受者都必须是伊朗公民。但除此之外，它的实践在不同省份有所不同，取决于你在哪里。西格丽德最初看到的相当令人不安。
The first donor I interviewed at the broker told me, if I'm not allowed to sell my kidney, what will I do?
我在经纪人那里采访的第一个捐献者告诉我，如果我不被允许卖我的肾，我会怎么做？
[SPEAKING IRANIAN]
[说伊朗语]
I'm poor. I'll have to steal or kill someone.
我很穷。我将不得不偷窃或杀某人。
In Tehran, Sigrid learned donors and recipients actually haggled over the price of the organ. There's a base price that the government sets for a kidney. And it covers a third of that cost. Anything above is negotiable.
在德黑兰，西格丽德了解到捐献者和接受者实际上在为器官价格讨价还价。政府为肾脏设定了一个底价。它覆盖了该成本的三分之一。以上任何事情都是可以谈判的。
And recipients are able to manipulate the negotiations by playing on the sympathy of the donors. One donor told Sigrid that when he met his recipient, the man's wife and children were crying in the room. Then they low-balled him with an offer of 3 million toman, about $3,000.
接受者能够通过利用捐献者的同情心来操纵谈判。一位捐献者告诉西格丽德，当他遇到他的接受者时，那个人的妻子和孩子们在房间里哭泣。然后他们以 300 万托曼，约 3000 美元的报价压低了他。
And so the guide said, they introduced me to the recipient's family and said, "see, look, he's poor, right. He can't do any better than this for you."
所以向导说，他们把我介绍给接受者的家人说，“看，看，他很穷，对吧。他不能为你做得更好。”
And he says, "OK, OK, I'll do it for 3 million." And so the guy donated. And then he's sitting next to someone in the waiting room, who got 6 million toman. What was clear in Tehran is the balance of power was clearly off in favor of the recipients.
他说，“好吧，好吧，我会以 300 万做。”所以那个人捐献了。然后他坐在候诊室里旁边的人，得到了 600 万托曼。德黑兰清楚的是力量平衡显然不利于接受者，有利于他们。
There were kidney donation centers that were supposed to make sure the transactions were fair. But--
有肾脏捐献中心应该确保交易公平。但——
Donors were being cheated. And all of them, more or less, in one form or another, were disappointed. And you know, I'm like, oh, my god, everything I thought would be the worst is here. I was depressed. I was like, my gosh, if this is what it's really like, then this isn't the answer. But then I went on to a couple other regions, where I saw models where people generally were happy with the system.
捐献者被欺骗了。他们所有的人，或多或少，以一种或另一种形式，都感到失望。你知道，我就像，噢，天哪，我想到的所有最坏的情况都在这儿。我很沮丧。我就像，我的天，如果这真的是它像什么样，那这就不是答案。但然后我去了其他几个地区，我看到了人们对系统普遍感到满意的模式。
This was in Isfahan and Mashhad. And the way these kidney donation centers worked was totally different. People who show up wanting to sell a kidney usually have a problem that money would solve. And in Isfahan and Mashhad, the donation centers did a much better job of looking out for their interests.
这在伊斯法罕和马什哈德。这些肾脏捐献中心运作的方式完全不同。出现想要卖肾的人通常有一个钱能解决的问题。而在伊斯法罕和马什哈德，捐献中心在照顾他们的利益方面做得好得多。
Like in Tehran, they would be told, well, the recipient can't pay that much. Their family is poor. And we haven't got enough charity money. So you're only going to get half that.
像在德黑兰，他们会被告知，嗯，接受者付不起那么多钱。他们的家人很穷。而且我们没有足够的慈善款。所以你只能得到那的一半。
Instead, in Isfahan and Mashhad, they would say, OK, how much do you need; what you need it for-- to get out of debt, to start a business, to start a family? You want this much for the organ donation. Let's see if we can do that for you.
相反，在伊斯法罕和马什哈德，他们会说，好的，你需要多少钱；你为什么需要它——摆脱债务，开始生意，开始家庭？你想要器官捐献的这多少钱。让我们看看我们能为你做些什么。
If they have to give the donor a little less they'll say, well, let's get you a loan to make up the difference. Because they're considering the donor's needs as well as the recipient's needs. I can't think of one that we interviewed who didn't get the deal they expected and needed.
如果他们必须给捐献者少一点他们会说，嗯，让我们给你一个贷款来弥补差额。因为他们不仅考虑接受者的需求，也考虑捐献者的需求。我想不出我们采访的任何一个没有得到他们预期和需要的交易的人。
The kidney centers also tried to provide food, clothing, follow-up care, free health care for the donors and their families.
肾脏中心也试图提供食物、衣服、后续护理，为捐献者及其家人提供免费医疗。
And they also get-- the males, they have two years mandatory military service. And males who donate get exempted. And the reason they get exempted-- and see, this is what I think is kind of beautiful-- they get exempted from military service because they have already served their country and humanity by saving a life.
而且他们也得到——男性，他们有两年强制性兵役。捐献的男性获得豁免。他们获得豁免的原因——看，这是我认为有点美丽的事情——他们从兵役中获得豁免，因为他们已经通过挽救生命服务了他们的国家和人类。
It's not that things were perfect in Isfahan or Mashhad. There were still plenty of people selling their kidneys out of desperation. But Sigrid says the people she interviewed came away feeling good about what they'd done.
并不是说伊斯法罕或马什哈德的一切都很完美。仍然有很多人因为绝望而卖掉他们的肾脏。但西格丽德说她采访的人离开时对他们所做的事情感觉良好。
When Sigrid came back to America from Iran, she thought long and hard about what she'd seen, about how many lives were saved because donors were able to sell their kidneys. And then she concluded, nope, definitely not something we should try.
当西格丽德从伊朗回到美国时，她仔细思考了她所看到的，思考了因为捐献者能够卖肾挽救了多少生命。然后她总结说，不，绝对不是我们应该尝试的事情。
I thought this was really good. But I was very hesitant to assume that what works in the Iranian culture would work here.
我想这真的很好。但我非常犹豫是否假设在伊朗文化中起作用的东西在这里也会起作用。
So why not?
所以为什么不？
That is a political question, OK, because there is so much opposition and misunderstanding what paying a donor means. That would never pass muster, not with the ethicists, not with Congress. But having my expenses covered is a different issue. I see no problem with that.
那是一个政治问题，好的，因为有太多的反对和误解支付捐献者意味着什么。那永远不会通过考核，不仅是伦理学家，也不是国会。但让我的开支覆盖是一个不同的问题。我看不出这有什么问题。
So this is what Sigrid believes we should do in America. Instead of having people make money off of selling their kidneys, Sigrid says we should just cover their costs. Right now, it's really expensive to donate, about $5,000 on average. But that can go up to $20,000, most of that lost wages.
所以这就是西格丽德认为我们应该在美国做的事情。与其让人通过卖肾赚钱，西格丽德说我们应该覆盖他们的成本。现在，捐献真的很昂贵，平均约 5000 美元。但这可能上升到 20000 美元，大部分是损失的工资。
Medicare covers the donor's medical expenses. But it would help donors out a lot and probably convince others to donate if the government paid for every transplant-related cost-- lost wages, transportation, babysitting, psychological assistance after the surgery. If we could prevent people from losing their jobs for taking time off to donate, Sigrid says this is a first step to treating our donors with the respect they deserve.
联邦医疗保险覆盖捐献者的医疗费用。但如果政府支付每一笔移植相关的成本——损失的工资、交通、保姆、手术后的心理援助，那将极大地帮助捐献者，并可能说服其他人捐献。如果我们能防止人们因为请假捐献而失去工作，西格丽德说这是对待我们捐献者以应有尊重的第一步。
She's tried to get this going herself. She founded a nonprofit that raises money to help donors cover their costs. So far, they've helped support 68 transplants. Other countries, like Ireland and Singapore, have already put systems like this in place, very different systems from what we have now.
她自己尝试让这件事进行。她创立了一个非营利组织，筹集资金帮助捐献者覆盖他们的成本。到目前为止，他们已经帮助支持了 68 例移植。其他国家，如爱尔兰和新加坡，已经把这样的系统放在位，非常不同的系统从我们现在有的。
You know, when I was turned down to donate, I was insulted and my friend died. I'm sorry. But if we are going to help solve the organ shortage, we cannot do it at the expense of donors. Because you don't take advantage of people who want to be altruistic like that.
你知道，当我被拒绝捐献时，我受到了侮辱，而我的朋友死了。我很抱歉。但如果我们打算帮助解决器官短缺，我们不能牺牲捐献者的利益。因为你不应该利用那些想以那样方式利他的人。
Right. Having your expenses covered would have solved your situation with Maurie, right?
对。覆盖你的开支将解决你与莫里的局面，对吧？
Right, it would have.
对，它会有的。
Anyway, that's one way to do it.
总之，那是那一种方法。
Stephanie Foo is one of the producers of our show.
斯蒂芬妮·富是我们节目的制作人之一。
Our program was produced today by Neil Drumming, Zoe Chace, Sean Cole, Stephanie Foo, Chana Joffe-Walt, Jonathan Menjivar, Robyn Semian, Lilly Sullivan, Alissa Shipp, and Nancy Updike. Our senior producer is Brian Reed. Our editor is Joel Lovell. Julie Snyder is our editorial consultant. Our technical director is Matt Tierney.
我们的节目今天由尼尔·德拉明、佐伊·蔡斯、肖恩·科尔、斯蒂芬妮·富、查娜·乔夫-沃尔特、乔纳森·门吉瓦尔、罗宾·塞米安、莉莉·沙利文、艾丽莎·希普和南希·厄普代克制作。我们的高级制作人是布莱恩·里德。我们的编辑是乔尔·洛弗尔。朱莉·斯奈德是我们的编辑顾问。我们的技术总监是马特·蒂尔尼。
Production help today from Lyra Smith. Producer help today from Christopher Swetala, Benjamin Anastas, and Benjamin Phalen. Music help today from Damien Graef, from Rob Geddis.
今天制作帮助来自莱拉·史密斯。今天制作帮助来自克里斯托弗·斯韦塔拉、本杰明·阿纳斯塔斯和本杰明·法伦。今天音乐帮助来自达米恩·格拉夫，来自罗伯·格迪斯。
[ACKNOWLEDGEMENTS]
[致谢]
Our website, thisamericanlife.org. This American Life is delivered to public radio stations by PRX, the Public Radio Exchange. Thanks as always to our program's co-founder, Mr. Torey Malatia, who asks me, at least once a week--
我们的网站，thisamericanlife.org。《美国生活》由公共广播交换机构 PRX 传递到公共广播电台。像往常一样感谢我们节目的联合创始人，托雷·马拉蒂亚先生，他至少每周问我一次——
Snag them, dynamite them, gillnet them.
用钩子钩它们，用炸药炸它们，用流刺网捕它们。
I'm Ira Glass, back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯，下周回来带着《美国生活》的更多故事。